[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the death eaters
and the followers of lord voldemort more
specifically
however we're going to be discussing one
follower in particular
notorious mass murdering werewolf fenrir
greyback
now not unlike our own world the
wizarding world is broken up into
two types of people the morally
righteous
and the morally corrupt this dichotomy
is a common theme in literary works
and in harry potter the darker side of
the spectrum
is represented by the death eaters it
all started
in the late 1930s when a young man by
the name of tom riddle
began attending hogwarts on the outside
riddle appeared to be a normal
respectable young man but on the inside
deep down
he had a lot of demons demons that
pushed him
to do unthinkable things he didn't have
a mother or father figure
he was just left as an orphanage and so
he never had any true concept of love
or family this rough start to life only
made riddle worse
as if he had been adopted by a loving
family things could have potentially
been different
he was conceived under a love potion and
this fact
suggests that he is incapable of love
but rowling also stated that if
riddle's mother were around to care for
him then he would have been able to
comprehend love
love aside riddle didn't even have a
concept of friendship
which is why riddle's time at hogwarts
was so significant
when riddle began at hogwarts he was
sorted into slytherin house
and it didn't take long for him to form
a group of friends at least that's what
it looked like
of course these friends were really just
his followers
a group once described by dumbledore as
a mixture of the weak seeking protection
the ambitious seeking glory and the
thugish seeking a leader
who could show them more refined cruelty
initially these friends
were known as the knights of walpurgis
but fast forward to 1970
and they were known by a different name
the death eaters
at this stage voldemort had decided to
fully act on his dark nature
and he brought other witches and wizards
along for the ride
the death eaters were the most loyal
followers of voldemort
obeying his every bidding in an effort
to cleanse the wizarding world
the goal of the group was simple
establish pure blood authority
given that voldemort's goal was to
basically oppress anyone that wasn't a
pure blood witch or wizard
you'll be surprised to hear that some
members of the group weren't actually
pure bloods in fact many of their
followers were of breeds
that death eaters held considerable
stigma towards people like fenrir
greyback
fenrir greyback was a large vicious
looking werewolf and follower of
voldemort
notorious for his savagery and brutality
when it came to targeting children
he had a beastial appearance with matted
gray hair whiskers
pointed teeth and long yellow nails he
was a nightmare-inducing figure
however greyback wasn't always such a
monster in fact
he had quite a rough start to his life
being bitten by a werewolf
very early on and infected with
lycanthropy
lycanthropy involves a lycanthrope also
known as someone who transforms into a
werewolf
sometimes they do it purposely but other
times it is the result of a curse
there is no cure for lycanthropy and
people deeply fear this condition
as it can result in a cursed existence
after being bitten
fenrir went sour and made it his goal in
life to infect as many people as
possible
with lycanthropy he didn't want to be an
outcast and with so much stigma placed
on lycanthropes he embraced his
condition
and instead made it his goal to create
enough werewolves to dominate the
wizarding world
greyback became a leader in the werewolf
community and was even the one to infect
remus lupin with lycanthropy
after lyle lupin remus's father insulted
werewolves
despite leading a revolution of his own
fenrir greyback and the werewolves
eventually became allies with voldemort
for the second wizarding war however
it's worth mentioning that though they
were followers of voldemort
they did not bear the dark mark nor were
they actual
death eaters they were just his
followers with that being said
fenrir was one of voldemort's most
useful weapons a fear-inspiring
bloodthirsty werewolf that even
frightened just a little bit
albus dumbledore is that you fenrir
asked dumbledore that's right
rasped the other pleased to see me
dumbledore
no i cannot say that i am fenrir
greyback grinned
showing pointed teeth blood trickled
down his chin
and he licked his lips slowly obscenely
but you know how much i like
kids dumbledore am i now to take it do
you are attacking even without the full
moon
this is most unusual you've developed a
taste for human flesh
that cannot be satisfied once a month
that's right
said greyback shocks you that doesn't it
dumbledore
frightens you well i cannot pretend it
does not disgust me little
said dumbledore and greyback raised a
yellow fingernail
and picked at his front teeth leering at
dumbledore
i could do you for afters dumbledore and
despite voldemort using him as a weapon
and taking advantage of his fearful
reputation it's reinforced again and
again
that greyback was not a death eater
voldemort only used him for the useful
and convenient services that he provided
basically
anything that helped him to get to power
quickly you haven't heard of him
lupin's hands closed convulsively in his
lap
fenrir greyback is perhaps the most
savage werewolf alive today
he regards it as his mission in life to
bite and to contaminate as many people
as possible
he wants to create enough werewolves to
overcome the wizards
voldemort has promised him prey in
return for his services
greyback specializes in children bite
them young he says
and raise them away from their parents
raise them to hate normal wizards
voldemort has threatened to unleash him
upon people's sons and daughters
it is a threat that usually produces
good results
so now you might be asking why if fenrir
crayback produced such good results of
the dark lord
was he not made to be a fully fledged
death eater
in the text it's highlighted that
greyback was not granted this honor
will you summon him here said scabio
sounding ored terrified no snarled
greyback
i haven't got they say he's using the
malfoy's place as a base
we'll take the boy there harry thought
he knew why greyback was not calling
voldemort
the werewolf might be allowed to wear
deathy to robes when they wanted to use
him
but only voldemort's inner circle were
branded with the dark mark
greyback had not been granted this
highest honor
greyback had no dark mark which is why
he couldn't summon voldemort in this
instance
furthermore greyback wouldn't have ever
been eligible to receive a dark mark
because of the very fact that he was a
lycanthrope
as i mentioned earlier there is
considerable stigma in the wizarding
community toward werewolves
and that stigma is not exclusive to the
good guys
it was a mutual feeling between both
sides of power
in the wizarding world here's the thing
fenrir was a powerful weapon
and voldemort knew that he would be able
to take advantage of fenrir's notoriety
to help control the wizarding population
and escalate
his own rise to power it didn't matter
to voldemort that he was a werewolf
not really he held some stigma towards
him which is why he would have never
made him a death eater
but voldemort's real enemies were muggle
borns half bloods muggles
and blood traitors fenrir wasn't the
only follower of voldemort that wasn't a
pure blood wizard
he enlisted giants dementors and all
other manners of dark creatures
to help bring down the ministry and the
good guys
voldemort was manipulative and he
basically did whatever it took to get to
power
the fastest if people were willing to
work for him under the guise that they
were somehow
important he would certainly let that
happen it was a win-win
for him however given that fenrir's
ultimate objective was to infect
as many witches and wizards as possible
with lycanthropy
i'm willing to bet that if voldemort had
achieved power and was victorious at the
battle of hogwarts
he would have eradicated the werewolves
not because he particularly wanted to
kill them
but because they would have posed a
threat to his regime
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time remember wit beyond
measure
is a man's greatest treasure
[Music]
you